did you smoke leave Japan my life even
with no place everything only one or two
fighters did it help man I swear
asleep but the sleep you get from weed
and like just a recovery you get off it
like to talk about before I mean he
broke the students [ __ ] spine right
he broke a vertebrae all right everybody
welcome to another episode of hot boxing
I'm Evan Britton and Mike Tyson hell
yeah we got a great guest today brother
great couple of guests the pedis and
aney and sergio but that's pretty
interesting
welcome guys want to put these
headphones on put the headphones on
these dudes were smoking weed before the
show brother got a little stove crap the
only way to go yeah not for real that's
good so brother UFC fighters yes pretty
awesome it's pretty awesome yeah I mean
you start first why started outside at
first we started with Taekwondo yeah
what do you say now he was my basketball
coach before he started he was a stop
basketball coach to me and has his first
fight I was addicted after I saw amazing
oh he's snap dude you got knockout what
24 second 24 seconds first fight yeah
yeah some good fights haha damn dude so
you guys did you grow up fighting each
other kinda yeah well you train with
each other so I mean we should be spar
everyday we spar like twice a week so
it's like that's more like bowling you
know well let me the reason I ask is
that we've got one of our buddies is
Cody gar Brant yeah Cody and his brother
Zach I don't know if you've ever met
Zach now I haven't saxophones
heart of gold but they grew up literally
beating the [ __ ] out of each other dude
damn and I'm like [ __ ] dude
it's just a hard brotherly relationship
you know my brother and I we got into a
lot of fights
it was always cool I brought the beat
the living [ __ ] but you guys in real
life real like I going to make people
like say I'm gonna playing with him on
the roof when I'm coming out of 5 ski
and I go knock my house and he's in the
back if he in the shower or something
and I see his [ __ ] money on the death
come on dogs I'll take his money my dad
died when I was 16 is killed in a house
robbery across the street from my house
man so like at a young age I was 16 he
were 9 years old 10 years old so um you
know it was like at that point in my
life I had to figure out like how for me
was like I was lost you know I'm like 16
in high school I'm like now I don't know
what I'm gonna do with my life but then
I knew I had a little something looking
up to me kind of and I I wouldn't say I
filled my dad's shoes but I kind of made
sure he was good you know I did whatever
I did I included him you know and so
changed our dynamic of a relationship
immediately I brought his clothes really
close I was the youngest of my family I
didn't like my family structure and
stuff so I went to look I looked up to
the people in the streets and stuff you
know no one ever questioned them they
have to be they didn't have to give
answers to nobody and stuff I said why
that's cool yeah yeah you won't even
have yeah you accomplished a Fisher
makes sense how old are you guys 1:32 25
[ __ ] [ __ ] thought I was old
and can I get to get Fitness at 32 it's
beautiful trust me you guys are
beautiful yeah let's say advantage
yeah yeah almost like this I mean when
you get our certain things probably in
your forties you got you know every [ __ ]
coughs you gotta be careful which [ __ ]
might be a laugh [ __ ] [ __ ] count holder
you gotta choose you can't say I'm gonna
hit that for the fullest and I gotta
hold it you gotta plant them out before
I hit that today baby no I'm a with that
one or that one
no more laughing told me that [ __ ] only
good for two I just try to soak up the
wisdom of Mike now ya may know cuz I
feel that way too I'm 31 and I'm like
[ __ ] dude I've lived a thousand years a
lot coming so how's learning some
experience of life oh yeah I'm excited
it's a hell of a ride man
it's beautiful you know it's being just
this stone highway this is where it gets
tricky you know it's a beautiful ride
then sometimes it's a nice away where
the [ __ ] am I going this can dig fit you
know the words that I'm talking right
now Harley that no one hears I hear only
in my brain this can't just end like
this I get old like dying I don't going
away is it black and this is that's
gonna be enough next test of your
journey where do I go from here you
think about that was [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] happy when this is over we only
have a certain life expectancy yeah sure
say we get to a hundred that's nothing
you know me yeah so what do we do after
that do we get don't exist anymore
you can't believe that we can't you know
you don't exist it's just talking we
don't exist no more damn those deeper
deeper we go deep
we go deep way that's why some people
that's why some people get high in the
reality of the world that's about
subconscious tumblers this is too deep
for us to handle sober yeah you know
some people kill themselves good said
hey I won't take me back subconsciously
saying I want to go back home I can't
take this mmm
it's just how that's why things happen
the way it is
why would somebody that's living the
greatest life in the world have all the
money of all the [ __ ] all the cars
nice home with myself [ __ ] this boom I
can't do this it's a good question
that's my dream what he's talked about
if that guy just killed themself in
here's everything I manage this guy this
guy's a [ __ ] in my mind what I [ __ ]
this problem you know but then coz it's
deeper things in life you feel you
haven't accomplished them you know you
feel you have everything life told me I
need to be the man to be gratified that
beasts be happy and this doesn't make me
happy something that came from my Vista
and then you start to worry real fast
I'll never find it instead of start
looking outside of what we believe is
our greatness you know exactly you guys
think about that yes I think well my
career man I had the highest highs
lowest lows I was on the cover of the
weeds box man and then I lose three
fights in a row and lady Sanders just
caught like this can't be it like I
don't I can't identify myself as just a
fighter you know there's more to it than
that there's more to it than my
happiness it has to come from something
else than my career so uh that's crazy
man especially the fight game termite
those most like we're especially with
social media man we're judged so hard
like you anything we do is judge so hard
people are our honor so I mean what
people can't handle depression to kill
themselves yeah they being judged by too
many people they can't take it they
can't handle the pressure which they
believe is negative negativity or the
fact that they are failure it may appear
that their faith because too many people
are telling they were wrong and they may
have been wrong but that doesn't mean
you give up yeah if somebody exposure to
something you don't want people to know
about your life that don't mean you give
up and kill yourself I wanted to told
them if I did the toll right
they were here but the toll
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh God die [ __ ]
[Music]
the only gift that you do
Patito
died left before is the quietest was so
like that the glorious death
I felt the feeling no one said nothing
as expose me but I felt the feel of it
all my secrets were exposed to everybody
I ever knew and never wanted to know
what I knew or what I did and that's so
far everybody know I said oh [ __ ]
I'm not [ __ ] I'm oh [ __ ] everybody knows
this about me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and that's
just what it was I was worried about
what everyone thought about me
I've had these secrets all my life I
don't want knowing and so I took the
total in it and I received the feeling
of everyone knowing you know the toad
DMT yeah yeah yeah how long is that less
well 15 minutes but dig that's you get a
thousand a thousand years of experience
and 15 minutes let our path that's
coming at you mouthing is coming at you
feels like forever
no it goes really fast and a real fast
right and then when I go
it's thought from you being a baby do
you being old then you evaporate
you're nothing but you still exist you
have nobody you still existing you
existing that's know you are ready
brother
you already that's what we all think
that we're not ready you know yeah how'd
you set that up yeah how do you set that
experience well somebody was being
interviewed with me and named talking me
about this [ __ ] this can do to us get
the [ __ ] out of here where did that you
know me and anything already later then
because we did more of then where's the
[ __ ] I really want to take this cuz
he was talking about it we going to
another dimension and it's meeting God
and all this yeah yeah and then when I
took it I smoked it and I said well they
hit me out in exhale in the hit boom
right I said I [ __ ] up these white
[ __ ] guys [ __ ] trying to prove
I tried to prove I [ __ ] up oh [ __ ] I
[ __ ] up I [ __ ] up I'm dead I'm
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] up they killed
whoa I'm serious
I never thought did you do it I haven't
done that yet I've done DMT and
ayahuasca I was that ayahuasca that's
same kind of powerful this is right it's
slower though needs an hour listen when
this stuff hit you right you're gonna
feel every feel of anything you ever did
in your life candy drugs sex bug you
feel every feeling of all of it if
you'll a bit there we go yeah baby
mother hugging you milking you every oh
sheesh Nega here for Oh what are you
doing over here that's it I could feel
that dude so ayahuasca that was where'd
you do that if you were to start with
something that's what you would go with
that Wasco you think well I'm getting
ready to do combo now I was now you just
go straight to the big time you go
straight to the toes you're not gonna
get any any intense feeling than that
all that's just leading up to the total
yeah Sam I don't know the toad is the
top of the pyramid
yeah is it like this is like mushrooms
like kind of that feeling or Z wait
let's just do not listen you whatever
you want you going and say boo myself
tennis I want power but you can't
believe it when you're feeling every
feeling you think you have that we're
hiding or everything's out the feeling
so so sensational you just it's like you
feel like you're a star or a Sun just
exploded it sounds amazing it sounds
well when you're ready for it it'll come
to you Memphis yeah definitely Tia's of
people doing it I'm like I don't know if
I'm ready for that know that show on
voice right yeah all that stuff moving
around you don't feel that now i skabble
my head can I hit my head cuz I fell off
the bed she's been on the floor but um
yeah you don't know anything listen you
forget everything you forget everybody
you love your kids you bear everything
you
go with the bigger thing your life and
you can live without you don't even
forgive forgot it doesn't exist anymore
sounds free yeah that's crazy
it's imagine everything that you holding
deep in your mind and your heart right
now that makes you still it doesn't
exist no more now you're dealing with
you it's all about you getting to know
who you are you none of that exists
nothing gets you dealing with who you
are statement yeah I mean I feel like
you are who would you but we think we
are our parents okay it's all that stuff
who are you who you're thinking right
now
whoever you think whatever you thinking
right now is who you are whatever it is
mines powerful man oh it's inconceivable
maybe for every fight my coach Duke my
coaches do rivers he sent me a quote
that uh your coach told you about
mindset Oh a ball like your opponent
like he's you know he's gonna I'm I had
to call my phone but how he's you in
your head you build them up to be this
crazy no absolutely mine is not to
friend exactly I quote exactly
I read that every for every fight in
mind to be your friend your mind
beautiful things about yourself and I
think about yourself all the time
because if you slack a bit tell you
ain't [ __ ] [ __ ] you gotta leave
[ __ ] fool but I'm not food [ __ ]
my inner self right that's the deepest
really [ __ ] ever met every training camp
I feel that Walter that right now I've
got two back-to-back losses mine's a
little all over the place don't don't
don't look at it keep that and do the
Adam yeah keep that belief and deep down
confidence in yourself for sure
you know me listen we don't tell nobody
they could they could be scientific that
you lost the fight that you did this
move but we know in fact why we lost the
fight but I spit a little bit we didn't
give her a hundred bucks
110 we're after a true person that we're
capable of being in that particular
moment we know why we lost nobody could
tell no announcing those trainers guitar
cuz they're not in our soul we know why
we lost
who is we who we ballin' the name of the
game when especially a fighter an
athlete or something and then life in
general a businessman we have to
overcome ourselves to fight us within
ourselves have to beat ourselves
the discipline yeah you know don't what
you hate to do Badou like you love it
yeah you know yeah absolutely and our
brain is programmed needed to hear that
to make us scared to keep us alive you
know that about it our brain is
programmed to constantly be assessing
and analyzing the data that's coming in
so that it can best figure out if you're
in a safe situation so as a fighter if
you're getting ready to go into a fight
a situation that you know is going to be
violent your mind the whole time is
trying to figure out how to talk you out
of doing that you know so that's up to
you like Mike said through that positive
visualization yeah to overcome that it's
a battle every every fight man every
every time especially an MMA UFC like in
boxing if you lose it's a different than
the UFC like UFC you got ten losses and
still be the man like it's just it's
just so quick of a sport or just fans
are quick to forget but um like throwing
off two losses I've done that - coming
off of two losses it's really mental man
so all the time he's in a spot where are
you I have been there before yeah
the biggest tragedy in fighters is not
when he lose to a better fighter that's
not a big tragedy the big tragedy and
fighting is when a person loses to
himself you know when he defeats himself
that's the biggest tragedy in fighting
you know a whole purpose my life ISM to
challenge ourselves and challenge the
belief that we were told who we were
what we were which is not necessarily
true you know we don't lose really the
actions are why my hair Who am I
besides my first and last name and my
mother's know who the [ __ ] am i why am I
here for what reason Steve how about
after fighting when you retire did you
do you miss that feeling of like getting
ready for competition and that that that
like challenge of a training camp you
say that no one I myth I'm not a myth
doctor I hated training I don't wanna
fight that hated training and stuff and
um I used to gonna fight you know train
a little biscuit that might wake up
normally when I again I was I had the
train just to lose the way
you know but sometimes I will just going
fight do not trim my training it's
because my ego I'm a superior fighter
he's [ __ ] guys not either [ __ ]
infected bugs and I said crazy about
[ __ ] my stuff and taking the total a
felt all the pain of everyone I have a
hell hurt when I wasn't old and stuff
and things I said to him I humiliate
them in front of people the world and
the television if I beat them with
something because I was so insecure
about who I was and stuff
Sam it exposes you know yeah yeah Steve
you guys believe in the afterlife I
really believe it is I do you have to
believe in it yeah someone someone that
says they don't believe it it's not
because they're looking for a safe place
to go when they die it's because they
haven't came in touch with who they are
how could I down how could I not exist
I'm no I'm a child of God I can I not
exist it's not in this world another
world I cannot really how can the energy
that you have right now and the stuff
that you could hear in your mind when
you're not talking nobody else is
talking how could this die how could the
feeling you have when your body could
have a hunk of that energy up you get
shot to just die I think my dad died man
like I went through this phase of like
questioning a religion question like why
did it happen to me at 16 years old like
it was crazy the crazy time of my life
but um man I feel like I could feel him
touching me and blessing me man like I'm
a kid from Milwaukee Wisconsin and I'm
doing this right here smoking doing this
interview with Mike Tyson like I
shouldn't be here and I could feel like
maybe that's just my connection with my
pops like we were we were very close but
like I could feel him guiding me still
man like I really feel it like I really
feel his presence in my everything I do
absolutely man in my opinion we've been
brainwashed in this material society
that we live in like there is nothing
that you can't see that's all
make-believe
but these bodies that we have are such
tuned antennae
- this sort of energy this ethereal
energy spirit higher power the
connection of everything we feel all
this [ __ ] but everybody just goes mad
it's not a now it's not it but it is it
yeah you know who do you guys think
about yeah and it has to be something
something more than the Hobby sitting
over just this is this life I feel like
did you start thinking that like at your
age now or before we started smoking
weed
I've always had this connection since I
was a little kid I've thought about this
I find myself doing that now I take
myself back in like moments of like my
last month my last fight and we're
walking out and I kind of like saw
myself walking out and I was like a
conscious a level of consciousness that
I've ever been to before like I already
saw the fight I saw my myself walking
out to the fight and I just I started
smoking weed about a year ago so like
he's been smoking longer than I have so
uh once once I started smoking weed I
feel like it opened this level of
consciousness up like when I went even
when I trained now I could see the
stakes I make and I could see like the
the things I need to change as far as
wondering if like weed to help you with
that or is that something what eight
maybe it's age I don't even know it
could be an age thing - I think we'd
cannabis is a tool I use frequently
because it puts me in a state of
consciousness where I have access to
information like what you're talking
about
does that make sense to you Mike
big-time did you smoke when you prepare
my life even with no spice everything
only one or two fighters smoked when I
was fighting did it help beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] man I swear
asleep at the sleep you get from weed in
like just a recovery you get I feel like
it's Mike's talked about before I mean
he broke this dude's [ __ ] spine right
you broke a vertebrae [ __ ] them up
listen while before before I started
smoking weed and stuff
weights again the fights all the [ __ ]
time off out of the ring yeah all the
[ __ ] time again fight the fighters
brother
animal did you feel like intuitively
mike weed was always something that
helped made you feel better well listen
I know when I was aired about smoke that
I felt good
I loved everybody yeah you know yeah
yeah sometimes after I did some
fucked-up I supposed to do and I wound
up going by a guy cars I'm like you
realize that type of [ __ ] is why you're
so legendary man that it's how you
could've been you know you could have
just been a fighter you know but you
were like you were helping people out
beyond anybody's idea of what that meant
at that time man no I was just I had so
much and I get in I thought that this is
my mindset right I said um maybe
somebody needed something what do you
need um I called the fifth too big a car
apartment or something a car whatever
you need that and I had so much nothing
and by my mind I would say you got all I
have to give you don't you or the [ __ ]
you or something hmm you know that
tripped me out so I said oh wait you're
really hot you're really beautiful you
have substance but huh take this car
take this house that was just my that
was just some a really dark way of um
understanding humanity yeah this and I
own you you take this I want you it was
never anything connection no connection
with my emotion on the emotions was my
dick well it makes sense well and I felt
like you know that's what can you just
give it to them instead of [ __ ] them
that's real [ __ ] you know but I you
know I guess a young kid and I didn't
are talking a [ __ ] girl and I just
had money I was Champa it's never had a
really girl I think the first time
really I was 18 19 was I'm really
building I was really did I became
champion you know yeah I didn't know I
didn't know what it was I take
I felt guilty getting given to people
giving me all this [ __ ] and [ __ ] for
free huh take this you know you did that
with girls but you also were doing that
for other reasons with dudes like the
game yeah you know like bringing young
rappers on and just like helping a
mountain show yeah you know poor they'd
have no money I used to be pretty let's
go there you have this sweet calling in
your girl them you can do whatever you
want everything's on the house order
anything is to live your life and that's
so awesome
hockey I can't I never understood how
could you be somebody like me to come
from where I came from and have so
[ __ ] much in the [ __ ] guy next to
you don't got [ __ ] yeah now you hung out
with it got you Paulie if we got hired
with drink together hung on you know got
[ __ ] oh that's [ __ ] ripped my soul a
bar I don't think life is [ __ ] fair
life can't be fair there can't be a
[ __ ] god yes
I I know that feeling man I just [ __ ]
all my life really bashing this guy's
never done nothing never stolen for it's
always been good his whole life nothing
yeah yeah yeah and I used to come back
to my neighborhood I used to say [ __ ]
this is where I'm from this should have
disguises sickness are you come on man
let's get some money let's get dressed
let's go wireless cuz I'm carless I saw
clubhouse man get us out awesome [ __ ]
apartment building by thought let's do
some [ __ ] man before he died yeah get a
[ __ ] [ __ ] room full of [ __ ]
naked girls go for it ha ha my friends
have never done anything like that don't
care how tough they are gangsters how
many people they killed they've never
been in a room with a bunch of necklace
and beautiful women
shooting out every day in the street
watching their block they've got enough
dead that was so uncomfortable yeah with
a bunch of naked women around they were
so [ __ ] uncomfy you would think they
would take the car they were like [ __ ]
we kept it cold what the [ __ ] going on
they don't know what they weren't like
happy they were like whoa what the
[ __ ] going on yeah mr. Schock no idea
about aliens
what about alien yo aliens remember in
Canada we saw some may not see my wife
my wife think we're aliens yeah my wife
think aliens planet is here yeah in did
they engineer us like they made us or
they or we are we respond by them I
think um I don't know I think we're
their flunkies with a [ __ ] leaf
we're like the workers yeah no name to
[ __ ] work at the airwaves we're the
work of David Phoebe there still be here
well manga yeah yeah we can even work
but we can't do [ __ ] for the Manley's
we're useless to them total
[ __ ] on planet Earth aliens are
still here orchestrating [ __ ] but in
like human suits listen I don't know you
tell me you think this is the only um
you think this is the only uniform God
can create I'm like it could have been
anything right now why don't we [ __ ] how
come we don't you know when we when we
belt sometimes it smells like [ __ ] but
why don't they come out of our mouths
after I ask ya dude why do we have two
arms why do we have two legs why do we
have these things why don't we have
tentacles why sometimes when people are
born they're born with an extra arm but
it's never it's never mature enough to
work yeah if that's something that we
that we're born with there one
particular time I won I don't know one
[ __ ] pie from [ __ ] we had three arms
three legs how come some people are born
with the tail trying to come out the ass
yeah it's real you know how it's amazing
stuff something that we want that and
they took away and it's still trying to
come out yeah oh no come on people you
know some people dictate bigger than
other people what about the elongated
skulls yeah that's all yeah yeah that
was interesting to what I'm feeling you
and yeah when people are doing that to
themselves oh yeah that's yeah I don't
know dude I don't think that makes sense
like they'd make theirs goes on no like
their that was like another race I think
that was another race of beings yeah
maybe those the first aliens were the
first humanoid aliens ah so laughing
faintest can't explain Mike I've said
this before but I'm gonna throw it out
to you again so you know there's this
tribe in West Africa called the Dogon
tribe I'm not hip tell me about them
they believe they worship cannabis and
every year they have like a month-long
cannabis festival in this tribe and it's
because in their folklore they have
these ancient cave paintings of aliens
coming down and they believe that these
this alien race from the Sirius stars
Sirius A and B for two stars they're the
dog stars they brought this alien race
brought this cannabis plant to humanity
to the people of Earth and gave it to
them and said this will bring you peace
you'll be able to use this this is a
very sacred plant that will help
Humanity in great ways now cannabis
translates to two dogs canna this the
two dogs from the to dog stars serious a
and B what if cannabis is from the
aliens
what is the toad might be from the
aliens yeah you know listen there and
Darin side um animals maybe the animals
are the gods right I think my dogs are
like guardian angels all the time listen
um I always explained that my wife hate
and hate bugs and she's always killing
bugs and in fact I think that could be
your grandmother you're so excited to
see you and think that she's the [ __ ]
bug I've never thought of that
somebody that we're happy to see they
forget the consciousness today I'm
[ __ ] bug and they're irritating you
and you smash them not knowing this dump
that'd be so kill anything don't kill
anything anymore I'm just a [ __ ] dog
guy because you find out I'm at the time
I come to my life called a paradigm
shift that we all come doing this in our
life because we find out everything we
were taught in our life was a lie
and now we got to figure out I hope
there was not too late for it to figure
out what's really going on who the [ __ ]
I really am you feel like you've had
that Mike oh absolutely
my whole life I thought I was a badass
[ __ ] ferocious savage don't give
nobody no [ __ ] pity [ __ ] though and I
found out just the scary [ __ ]
didn't want those guys to pick on me
anymore I wasn't going to do another his
hope that could scared him enough to
pick on me anymore and then wanted me to
see that little boy anymore
sometimes I see him because he comes out
sometimes and I think they saw so
sometimes I gotta get in that [ __ ]
chest just in case they saw a little boy
trying one day I have to live your life
like that
it's how hard man you're worried about
what somebody think about - you ready to
[ __ ] rip his [ __ ] eyes out cuz
you're so insecure
oh god life my family my they did a
number on me [ __ ] I'm glad you're here
about me - [ __ ] you're the man like
[Music]
thank you I'm big time glad I'm here
we're really glad you're here so who who
are you guys outside of being fighters
because you know the world wants to put
a label on you
yeah and say $25 of this and I don't
even know if that's true this is the
country might be a contradiction then
listen to the hi explain it then I don't
know if this yeah yeah just put it out
there man now that I had all the [ __ ]
in all the sex that I wanted that I
thought that I needed to have in life
right I think I could have done without
it right but what kind of person I would
have been if I never did that because
you're saying you would still have been
a guy who had the desire but you if you
were a guy who didn't exercise it no who
were you then
yeah I've been an ass everybody I think
right all of us do haven't some kind of
desire yeah desires an interesting thing
you know physical desire lust it's an
interesting you know it's very primal
it's very old but it's like an
instinctual but and no but um we only
needed for increments of our life yeah
but it leaves us [ __ ] unreliable you
you know learning it doesn't last long
yeah from a poem it's over yeah what's
my obligation to this what did what did
I what did I commit for this feeling
right it's crazy when I commit to for
this feeling yeah at this moment I don't
like [ __ ] anymore but I just had it and
now I gotta get commit something to it
mmm I don't have that shot my load I
don't like pushing away they can't do me
any favors and get hard right now so
what the [ __ ] that commit to real night
he committed to the remote to the
illusion that I love you right
I get I commit to that
that's now this is no losing I if not I
got nothing else to do I can't say not
into what do I say to you I'm not gonna
say thank you I'm I said I love you
right
but I don't love you but it seems like
the right thing to say that feeling just
gave me made me say I love you I haven't
gotten it from no one else yeah but
sometimes I think I want I want I want
to express that feeling when I her over
here okay I will do that no yeah isn't
that it's so complex emotionally sex no
sex in the meals no I know it's simple
but like what you're saying few women of
[ __ ] pigs
most men a pig but if you want me to
pick yeah and if she is the biggest you
you wrote it you you pushed in that
direction most men push women in that
direction for them to cheat I'll be pigs
and stuff they're not going to be
overtly pegs either because the man is
abusive oh he's so weak one of the other
hmm
yeah she despised his weakness so she
does that because a weight the weakness
allows him to get away with that but
that doesn't mean the weakness is bad
yeah you know I heard this thing once
that when you have sex with a person
their energy stays with you for seven
years
I do believe when we have fective juices
that go between each other and then go
inside you and it goes inside huh and it
makes a bond yeah
it doesn't have to be a sexual bond our
lower self get attracted to the to the
sexual bond the Fremen enemy but it
gives you more feelings a connection
with that person without being a side of
her you know yeah yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah feelings an empathy for you don't
know how to feel any pain yeah but you
don't want to be with uh sexually
anymore
yeah how do you explain that how do you
explain it how do we keep this feeling I
want to keep this feeling I have with
you but the only way I can have it if I
have to [ __ ] you I can't be friendly
which I can how
you can kiss you the way I want to
unless we have to have sex but I don't
have a sexual desire for you have a
loving desire to attach and I don't
understand now I don't [ __ ] like you
because I don't want to [ __ ] be
attached to you I can't control this
[ __ ] feeling [ __ ] you [ __ ] you can't
deal we can understand why I know me
[ __ ] you yeah
fellas dude that was a perfect
illustration like nation shape around
our conflict leads with a woman because
we can't possess her sometime yeah she
can't understand the fact why I need to
possess about I can't [ __ ] convey to
her why she needs to let me possess her
because as a man do you even know why no
something deep maybe it maybe and listen
maybe she's somebody from my life in
another world and God is giving me the
instinct to talk to her stuff I don't
know [ __ ] - there's always bigger
than that that is so unforgiving yeah
the act of sex with so insignificance
the wife that leaves us to ever laughing
feeling it's not love right happy time I
love like I don't know lovers could be
just an something that we made up in our
mind
well why is that why does it have to be
the word love hate weather that's why
I'd love it why I love it on in that
demanding respect even if you tell a
girl hey baby I love you stop [ __ ]
playing alright here you love me she
can't believe the fact that some I even
love her because it's so overwhelming
not even from a friendly perspective
that's overwhelming they wanted to be
known hey you love me - you know cuz we
all have a different perspective of love
it's good stuff yeah now no it's not
knowledge just we have time to figure it
out or smell it yeah I know I know I
don't know it know respective movies
like deep makes you think about it a
different level yeah yeah your brain is
complex this stuff it seems like this
stuff's been coming up Mike a lot no
because I say to myself from sometimes
why don't my wife love me feel much hmm
I've been so bad I've done so many bad
things so why does she love me so much
if my wife went out here and [ __ ] a
couple of guys it would only be right I
would have no I would have no reason to
be mad but of course I probably might be
me about what I've no reason to be mad
you know why do I do this might be
totally lawyer to me and I wasn't lawyer
to no and why would I did why would they
did I ever try to be Lloyd to me even
though I wasn't lawyer to them because
I'm Who I am who the [ __ ] am I in my
head if somebody should be Lloyd to me
for being a scumbag you know what
disease vaccine did I discover the heads
love ma'am
yeah you know that's love that's like a
sacred bond you know I feel that with my
wife I'm just like blown away all the
[ __ ] we've been through she's she's
still with me and loves me the way she
does I'm just like [ __ ] man I can do it
but someone else do it is [ __ ] wrong
you know that's just what I think
sometimes you know why is it like that
why should it be like that
why is which part like what like why in
human nature sometimes we don't know you
know we evaluate ourselves you know you
know we don't assess I felt what we do
wrong you know yeah well we will we can
figure heighten our subconscious that's
what my whole life has been about man
for the last few years it's like
everything you know everything that
everywhere that I can take
responsibility for my side of the story
I just have to surrender to that yeah
you know that's what I've tried to
figure out you know me if I try to keep
my fabulous treat clean that's it I
can't worry about other people with my
wife do with my kids doing stuff that's
it man and I've realized this thing like
you know you guys are talking about as
fighters and playing offensive line like
you know I really I resonate with a lot
of what you guys say about when you lose
you know because an offensive line you
know you're going 70
five times against another guy
hand-to-hand combat whether it's a run
play or pass play and if that guy beats
you as an offensive lineman gets a sack
you look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
you might have kicked that guy's ass 474
plays and one play he beat you for a
sack and that's all anybody talks about
you sucked and you know I've realized
man and this is not this was not during
my playing days because you know I would
definitely get pissed off about you know
negative things that were said if they
were you know but there's what everybody
thinks there's what everybody says it's
all out here there's what you think in
what you believe about yourself and then
there's your relationship to what
everything that's going on outside so if
you can learn to master this part of it
because what everybody else says and
what everybody else thinks doesn't have
any [ __ ] effect on you
it doesn't it has nothing to do with
anything real about your experience of
the world you know you only think that
it does you know especially as an
athlete you know and you start to and
that's what gets [ __ ] up and that's
why it's always about coming back to the
battle within you know because all these
people man nobody [ __ ] matters this
all might be in my head this whole thing
yeah this might all just be a dream and
when you can master that voice in your
head man and say you know what this
happened that's why I got beat and
that's okay
you know everybody [ __ ] gets their
ass kicked at some point everybody and
if you don't you're kicking the [ __ ] out
of yourself there's no doubt about that
you know cuz it's like we deal with my
opinion there like that we deal with
it's just challenges for us you know
you're great fighter you've been beating
people for a while that's great let's
see you handle loss let's get obliviated
boom let's get up just get the [ __ ] beat
out here and down bones all right now
that's cool - yeah
see how you handle that now we're not
fighting them when I was dealing with
life man go out go out the dressing room
go to your house take a shower go sleep
now you gotta get the next one [ __ ] you
gotta do man yeah dude you got you got
to do with your broken Joey I do with
your cut I'd it's got to be done
everywhere you go life continues yeah
look at the movies like your child's
school everybody's talking about what
happened in your file yeah we don't get
to play next Sunday if it takes five
months for these guys gotta wait happy
you'll have six months for six months
with this life I don't care no one say
you know but it's nothing like being in
the myth of the Beatles done it and even
Fairlight trying to accomplish it it's
just not no feeling like it it's the
feeling of objective of trying to become
great its greatness in itself imagine
want to take for your first step to say
I'm gonna be a fighter
I'm gonna follow my brother suddenly the
first [ __ ] step you gotta code with
the steps I go to the gym and see all
these other kids fighting there any more
experience than you laughter how am I
gonna get to that [ __ ] level this
guy's not gonna let me get to LA he's
gonna kill me you know I mean watching
these guys - hi I'm gonna buck i'ma
gonna get like he's gonna kill me
you know then little by little get the
grass bit more grass and when morning
stand this guy is human and he believes
and he he has problems - and you realize
that psychologically I can do this stuff
yeah you know see somebody always it's
always somebody say I hate these guys
found my I never looked up to any but if
somebody sees whoa that's what I want to
be right there you know yeah it's always
somebody you see you know when I first
saw I live here that's who I wanted to
be like I know wanted to be a fighter
but then I sort of a burden around I
said that's a little [ __ ] I want to be
no I said that's the way I want to be a
mean [ __ ] people scared to look
at him devil
yeah did you like use that in your
fighting style or the outside of the
cake outside you're both just that was
once an animal outside of the ring I
mean I've seen it yeah but that's the
one it's the little boy has to go do the
rest of Ron Victor's whole Cafe Cuban
restaurants go to everything sit outside
to wait to feel I had too many
bodyguards so I became famous fighter I
came chairman and I started going there
and I'd say whatever Duran eat show me
the food that he put to sleep me with
you gave the round steak steak yeah rice
that states rights and stuff yeah I said
I made them in the restaurant my hero he
that [ __ ] Sirhan was a monster
surveillance among listen let me tell
you something man listen Duran this guy
was giving the ran a tough fight so that
the 14th round around knocked him out
boom he's in a coma he's in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] up right
and then everybody said and so the Duran
says when they said man what are you
sillies in a coma the possibility may
not live and then the rancid pull next
time I be in shape he won't go to the
hospital go to the [ __ ] morgue so
awesome that's dope much he was gonna
fight this one guy named via Web my game
another tough fight it went the 15
rounds so Duran shook the got a 40
should give hand but when this corner
punch it's [ __ ] father in the faith
shoot the fight an but in the fighter
corner punched his father in the face
holy [ __ ] monster Sam do you see his
movie I made it about his life yeah
did you like it was crazy I I look at
the rank greater than that yeah what was
that movie got the name I forget the
name a few years ago yeah as commuters
ago
his life story but it's good ya see man
it's crazy you gotta look at the fact
you may be in a boxing fanatic and stuff
right
Durant was lightweight champion for
seven years couldn't be matchy lost one
fi'ty revenge they lost it extra banda
Hazel's right didn't under seven years
he was champion and then he fought the
great carlos palomino was welterweight
champion and non-title fight boom he
beat him and then he came to fight
sugaring and that was the biggest
fighting of my world in 1980 i watch
these guys fight in montreal can that
turn onto the screen of course that
turned me out i wanted to be a fighter
that would died and said no way I'm not
gonna be a fighter enough fight I want
to die so I wanted to be a fight after
out of 1414 Rita bottom I still watch
Peter go upstair the reader to read
about and read about goes running so
doing push-ups it and so I'm reading
about watching him fight on Tobin's so I
did nasty just like he was [ __ ] you I'm
the best fighter in the world air you
think you he was a [ __ ] you like
brain your brain washer so yeah big time
yeah that's awesome so sad to do and
know everything about the way hung out
where nobody that knew the people that
train from the stuff it's dope as hell
you guys have any idols like that anime
the lifted you up when you were coming
up for me it was like GSP and Anderson
Silva guys good guys SP lost yeah it was
a the martial arts for them for me was
like more subtly shows respect like I
come from a Taekwondo background so I
think that's what I draw took me towards
him yeah respect value for that but then
there's gilman guys are monsters yeah
they're to the best yeah no I really
like her life and finally has to be it
something that happened in the beginning
of humanity something because I'm
everything is all about submission and
is giving you know praise to God you
know I'm gonna fight him talk about
being humbleness you know there's some
guys that are [ __ ] and come out of
fighting and they're arrogant cuz you
know we're insecure but it's all about
your some being humble fighting because
we all fight we all win we all lose you
know yeah
and fighting spirit and its emotions and
stuff about controlling your emotions
controlling everything people being
controlling the fight and we lose when
we lose our concentration that's when we
lose when we lose our [ __ ]
concentration a moment of thought
it's deep it's exactly how fighting is I
think like now that I started smoking I
look at fighting like that like in
moments like you know natural instinct
from a punch is to pull away but like we
train ourselves to stay in it and like
that little that thought process right
there is what you're training to be able
to do for the duration of the flight if
I can keep doing this and stay and I can
I can actually win this fight so it's
it's really mental man it's like it's
crazy for sure
anybody could be big but you know it's
all about control your [ __ ] bodies on
the purpose of the cavity your brain
[ __ ] bodies you have your brain we're
like the robot yeah so I went up weight
class and I saw all that that that
mindset I used that in my last training
camp just understanding like my the guy
fought was way bigger than me was
supposed to win and number three in the
world and I was my first time fighting
in that way class I love that that mine
said I just took another training camp I
knew what I had to do it I know how
discipline I had to stay at it and I
just it weed I swear I'll help me stay
focused on that game that guy I'm gonna
fight for the title guy he did Wonder
Boy yeah yeah I thought I would Li twice
link with the years month he's a guy
that me would think about listen my mind
my ego will go like this
hey see what I did to see what tyron
woodley did to I [ __ ] my better than
champion for the [ __ ] champ
bring them on that's really that's why
you got there doing exactly do you guys
meditate
man I try my brain is just so all over
the place man like I supposed to be I
run a lot I have a couple other
businesses I own the barber shop so my
gyms and nice dude so my mind like when
I'm not fighting I focused right on that
because like I need the next the next
thing is we're upgrade something
yeah well that's great going back to you
know breaking out of that identity is a
fighter exactly and being more than none
another way to challenge myself because
like when I was only fighting that yeah
yeah I need like a challenge that was
like all right now what's after that
after my training camps done I get my
result if I didn't have the businesses
after that I something to focus on I'd
live in that moment like either I was
the champ and I was the man I won the
fight I've been the champ before I got
was I was man then when I put these
businesses in place I felt like it gave
me something else to focus on give me
nothing identity and like another thing
too just to get involved in so I mean it
helps a lot absolutely man I mean as
athletes we get so locked into what
we're doing that you know you forget
that you're a human being you know and
having businesses that's really creative
and you're working other parts of your
mind and you know you're expressing more
of your spirit into the world man it's
important to do do you have any
businesses no not yet I'm working on it
right now I just want to keep focus on
fighting nice thing about something with
him hopefully soon yeah absolutely
Pettis Bros incorporated fighting is
such a [ __ ] mind [ __ ] you know why
because sometimes you fighting that got
it looks like [ __ ] either monster yeah
it's gonna be easy fighting this guy the
[ __ ] monster yeah you think the first
time I talked him he's gone back he's
still come back he's like oh [ __ ] no you
know [ __ ] [ __ ] for my fight Val look at
the guy in his faith or look at his eye
and I was after finding the referee
would say go to your corner come on
fight I would turn around and I would
say oh [ __ ] to my dad he's come in the
fight oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] come in
the fight oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm ready
but favorite laughing cause I know he's
gonna come in and say oh [ __ ] [ __ ] is
nothing look at the guys they always
have gonna come you know I'm in with
hell holy [ __ ] Wow
yeah I just have one I'm Tony Ferguson's
one of them guys I bought him you just
know like you're going to the hospital
after that fight we're about touch
gloves you leg up the hospital's coming
after this fight you know it Wow
that's intense - Wow hell of a feel but
you know you're at your best to love
exactly right ready - he's going I'm
going he's going when that woman looking
at this [ __ ] guy
and going to the corner I'm saying my
trains a wife it's [ __ ] come in
to fight I said but [ __ ] meme I said
no [ __ ] I'm in the fight he coming
fight yeah
[ __ ] dude well that's how they had to be
man that's how you have to be I mean
[ __ ] no matter who you're facing you got
to just be coming ready to [ __ ] fight
ready to go to the hospital
exactly especially like back in his days
like somebody fought him they're like
trying to get his name so they were the
best of the best that could ever be for
their fight you know my Dyson is there
anything you guys want to shout out
before we wrap this thing up people
things how to get in touch with you
anything I want all my stuff is so
Showtime Pettis Instagram Twitter
Facebook and that's it just want to give
a shout out to everybody at Rufus port
all my training partners on my teammates
everybody Milwaukee thank you guys for
the love and support team Pettis and
follow me at Sergio Pettis pretty much
everywhere awesome man
Mike I appreciate this is an awesome
conversation you guys are two awesome
young awesome individuals man and we
should have better than anything we
appreciate yeah thank you for having us
Munoz I learned a lot so thank you guys
thank you thank you guys beautiful they
can appreciate you guys all right
everybody that was another episode of
hot box and I'm Evan Britain Mike Tyson
super Pettis Anthony Pettis ha ha are
your only two sisters anything now the
Pettis fan yeah all right y'all bye guys
subscribe to the YouTube channel
hot boxing with Mike Tyson don't forget
to toad
never exhibit oh yeah we're out of here
I'll be talking to incident
[Music]